you grow up and you have this such this
Rich tradition and now you're spending
uh you know good good portion of your
life in New York City yeah and you have
a family here yeah yeah and that must
feel like a disconnect sometimes it's
it's still to this day it feels like so
many things when I remember the one of
the first times it really hit home was
when we were driving we were driving
back into the City and then we cry we
live very close to the Brooklyn Bridge
and we we're crossing the Brooklyn
Bridge and the kids go oh we're home and
I went
this is part of a movie yes you can only
work a 10-hour day yeah you precocious
yes so and it's it's still
there are more I as I was coming in
today there are scenes I will I will
look at you know in in Times Square and
still feel like I'm in a school's easy
movie yes you're a taxi driver yes yes I
I'm giving the best performance of my
life but it it it it's it's still it's
it still hasn't sunk in there's where
where the kids play football has this
incredible view of Manhattan into the
kind of
Brooklyn the southern tip of my heart
and it has the entire view of that you
can see you can see the Chrysler Empire
so you can see everything from this from
a football field where the kids played
football and I said the other day I said
it is incredible that you will grow up
having this view from your soccer field
yeah and he went what View
ing
nothing doesn't matter kick the ball
yeah yeah it is it's like uh if you talk
to us uh if if one does talk to I try
not to but talk to a a small boy in
France in Paris who lives in the shadow
of the Eiffel Tower there's a good
chance he's never been up in it no no I
know it doesn't get it doesn't give a
no and no and no and understandably
no no should he Los Angeles you know I
was in I was seven years in Los Angeles
and that felt that felt a lot more
foreign to me that was truly the thing I
think we all grew up with this
incredibly exotic idea of Los Angeles
and it sort of doesn't disappoint when
you when you got off the plane you know
we were all heading over there for pilot
season with these with these giddy
Notions but LA to me and still has that
light and those palm trees that still
feel like it was everything I imagined
and wanted to do as a child and then
when I came to New York having spent 13
years in London I felt one step to what
I still felt in a movie but it was one
step towards somewhere I knew I was like
I can I can navigate the subway I know
you know this feels a little more the
Bars were a little more familiar I felt
like I was like okay I can be I can be
relatively comfortable you've clicked
back a little closer on the dial I have
I have that I can I can find my own
among these among these dirty streets
when you're you're a kid and you're
dreaming about
uh Hollywood yeah it was yeah what you
know who are the actors that really
spoke to you or the film actors were
there people that spoke to you and were
they necessarily any of the Welsh greats
or were you had you moved on to you like
Laverne and Shirley well I've always
been Shirley Cagney and Lacey all the
classics but right but
I think Burton was revered in Wales
because he was the tree he was the
Trailblazer the one who who not only
conquer he not only conquered well no
you know Hollywood he he he took it to a
round that we could have we can still
only imagine what because you know I
don't think there's a lot of young
people that listen to this they don't
understand that Richard Burton and
Elizabeth Taylor were this scandalous
couple
and they were whatever you think the
Kardashians are now in terms of pure
level of Fame yes or you know you know
uh Brad Pitt Angelina whatever you you
can imagine it was bigger because they
were the acknowledged biggest couple in
the world yes and for about eight years
and were whatever they did was news
right this show was sponsored by better
help
okay imagine you're looking at a scare
with everything you do for others on one
side and then on the other side of the
scale is everything you do for yourself
the question is is it balanced I think
in a lot of cases that's probably not
the situation well guess what therapy
can help you clarify your values find
more balance in your life so you can
keep being a rock star for others
without forgetting yourself in the
process to be honest I've never been a
rock star for anybody but but I get the
idea so if you're thinking of starting
therapy I think you've better help a try
here's the cool thing it's entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule so
what you do is you fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge and I
think one of the barriers to getting
therapy for a lot of people is
I don't know I gotta go in I got to sit
there with this person it's going to be
awkward what if it's not a good fit I'm
going to feel weird saying this doesn't
work for me and not coming back all of
that's eliminated uh with better help so
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com Conan today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Kona to a degree the
sort of first of that Paparazzi yes that
kind of would shut down blocks because
of you know the trail of Paparazzi and
and just just the extravagance of the
life that went with it the yachts and
the kind of outbidden he got her a giant
ring yes on the on the on the on the on
the gemstone or something you know all
those all those incredible stories are
inhaling from a tiny mining town in in
South Wales so it was he he was you know
I I read about him as a young boy and he
really was he was great friends with
Dylan Thomas so he he bestowed so much
in kind of Welsh mythicism and law for
me personally still does that he was you
know and then and then Hopkins from the
same time Anthony Hopkins from the same
town
followed in his footsteps and then and
then we were all and then we were off we
were like if right we're on right I want
to go back in time and be born in that
town I really do I know I want a time
machine yes yes I want to be born in
that town yes and uh then I'll get the
respect I deserve right Michael Sheen
also born in that town but then but you
know they these were they they set they
set the trail for us to kind of go it's
uh we're allowed now yeah it's it's
possible
do you do you are there any things that
you can do say with your family
that will bring them closer to your
childhood can you go out and this is a
uh I don't even know if this is
something that happens in Wales I'm just
making it up but can you say let's go
cut some peat for the fire
no we leave that to the Irish no one can
cut Pete like the Irish okay yes all
right that was a bad one how about this
no how about you dig a small mine
wherever you're living yeah uh just
outside get permission from the city to
build a small mind well that's what we
have going on in Brooklyn at the moment
we're going down another scene in a week
so we're very excited the kids are very
excited I'm old school so I like the
naked flame on the helmet yes of course
here's a canary for the morning off you
go you know you lower them on a road I
do Sing Sing dance yes yes
so so you know they get a sense of Both
Worlds I like that a sense of you know
Both Worlds and understanding funnily
enough for last year for the you know
Kerry was shooting back in London so for
the first time
and my son was six so I I got to start
um taking him back to those elements of
my childhood when we were kind of packed
off to the farms at early ages and we
went back to My Father's Farm
um and and that was that I did get quite
emotional at times but that was to me
was this incredible moment where I
started to show him all the old you know
Kodak photos of Me At Six yeah feeding
various livestocks or something like a
complete Welsh cliche but but yeah I was
I was incredibly happy to be to be able
to do that to kind of you know Link Link
Link my past more so than I've been
doing so uh yeah I would I mean that's
the other thing too is do you think your
your kid's gonna have an accent at all
it's gonna have can you just can you
give him tapes that he could listen to
it as he's sleeping at night I do speak
to him well now because I you know I was
I was raised speaking about
um and it wasn't any kind of conscious
decision when when he was born I just
started speaking to him in Welsh
um and he's now entering this phase
where he's realizing that I he calls it
data language and Mama language and he's
kind of getting it's not he's not
embarrassed by it but some well no he is
embarrassed by it because sometimes in
school he'll say hey can you speak
Mama's language and I go I go yes
absolutely but you know know that it's
it's our own secret language because I'm
pretty sure there's a very few in
Brooklyn that can pick up on our
conversation
um
so you know I I'm just trying to impart
things that
in retrospect I hope he'll go all right
he did he did he did pass on there there
are these these phrases these songs that
I can remember you know songs from my
father quote Marlon Brando's book yeah
did you it's funny what I'm passing on
to my kids is because my uh my wife is
very
uh you know she's a
um she's a wasp so she's she just is
she's uh she's uh I married someone
who's got uh ancestors with portraits
and um do they go back to the Mayflower
oh I'm sure they were they were on the
Mayflower these were people who they're
they're they're they're a mix of uh some
Welsh Scottish English a little bit of
Irish and then uh it's funny when I came
along uh their uh my my wife's
grandfather was uh
was just like oh you brought an Irishman
have you you know and I'm like well you
know we've been in this country a couple
of hundred years I'm well educated I
think I I clean up nice and
um
uh but he was suspicious he told me at
one point he called me over and he said
you know I just have to tell you I have
a problem with the Pope and I said well
I
yeah I said you know first of all it's
it's
2005. yeah
so but it was just funny that I think
when he looked at me he saw a leprechaun
uh who was trying to uh Pope loving yeah
yeah
papers uh so uh were you raised Catholic
Oh very Catholic right yeah very is very
Catholic and so
um have you so have you done have you
done genealogy have you done the kind of
I did and what were your percentages I
am 100 that's amazing congratulations
well I what I say when it's true is I'm
inbred
that's true they've kept that part of my
stand-up act for a while and people
would really laugh hard and I think they
always laugh at the true part
but of course you know you're only 100
Irish if if brothers are marrying
sisters for a couple hundred years
exactly so this is done
you passed the test you get the key to
the country now let alone the city pick
a city no it's true uh I would love I
always tell my kids your guys are a mix
this and you want to be a mix right
exotic right exotic mix yes of course
Irish with Scottish with English yes
with uh all bases covered yes yeah then
they can mix in any Social Circle
exactly yeah and passport to any many
small Celtic country they want
but anyway uh no you should think of
doing a remake of the I Love Lucy show
um where it's you and Carrie except uh
you know when he would when Desi would
get upset he would start babbling in
yeah like he'd get upset and he'd start
ranting yeah uh in Spanish yeah and I
think you could do the same show yeah uh
except you just go into wealth yeah I I
live that life I don't use that that's
life in our house where I kind of curse
and Welsh and kind of shout you know
what is this I don't even know a Welsh
swear what it sounds like
yes but you just sneeze yes I know
people people often say sometimes when
I'm speaking Welsh during covid you must
have been a terrifying person to be
around well of course they were like
get over here yes you are right sir yes
is that a lung yeah
what gave me great joy the other day was
actually hearing my son swear in Welsh
oh that's terrific yeah
I don't want to know what it means it's
just I just want to enjoy it it's like
yeah okay I'll let you I'll let you
imagine let my mind yes I can watch it's
like two little movie screens yes
two little beady movie screens you're
looking in my eyes